con esto se pesca la sardina juan carlos
garate tiene 68 años desde los 12 se
dedica a la pesca aquí en la isla del
espinillo él como todos en este lugar
está sorprendido con la histórica
seguida del paraná bueno es todo de esto
que vamos a ver acá es un arroyo este el
arroyo el saco se llama
en épocas normales este arroyo debería
estar rebosante tan alto como el propio
juan carlos está seco seco se conceptos
y tiene su
arroyo dice que van a lagunas que ahora
están secos tanto todo seco por la gran
bajante está todo el juan carlos junto
con esta comunidad de pescadores es uno
de tantos afectados por el marcado de
servicio del nivel de las aguas del
paraná se ha vuelto muy difícil poder
pescar como antes
desde que agarramos 20 con 120 brazadas
de tejido
2 abalo ahora recién agarre una boquita
tendrá 3 kilos y 2 abalo te parece que
puede como hundir a una persona hacia
mediados de 2021 algunos brazos del río
se veían así casi completamente secos
esta caída en el nivel del agua que aquí
se llama bajante aún persiste más allá
de mejoras circunstanciales llevan dos
años en esta situación frente a la isla
del espinillo en la ciudad de rosario se
encuentra uno de los 30 puertos de
granos de esta región del paraná el polo
logístico de este tipo de productos más
importantes del mundo por la poca agua
que hay a esta escalera que baja hacia
el río debieron agregarle un tramo es un
detalle pero el impacto en el comercio
de granos de la caída en el caudal de
agua ha sido enorme para cazar en el 80
por ciento de las exportaciones de la
argentina con 80 mil millones de
toneladas
entonces cuando tiene estas estas
situaciones críticas los barcos tienen
que salir con menos carga eso obviamente
le genera a la región una
pérdida de rentabilidad el derroche de
rebalse y el derroche de ingresos que
generan no solamente para el exportador
del producto sino para toda la región
hasta la misma provisión de agua potable
de la ciudad de estado en riesgo para
poder seguir captando los 600 millones
de litros diarios que necesita la ciudad
la empresa proveedora debió implementar
soluciones de emergencia
estas grandes cañerías transportan
aproximadamente el 15 por ciento del
total que captamos en esta planta y lo
tuvimos que hacer incorporando bombas
arriba de un pontón bombas flotantes en
reemplazo de otras bombas que ya no
podían trabajar porque estaban apoyados
y apoyadas en el lecho del río pero
cuáles son los factores que han llevado
a esta situación tan inusual en el
paraná con tan graves consecuencias
científicos como andrés y ara director
de la carrera de especialización de
ciencias ambientales y desarrollo
sostenible de la universidad nacional de
rosario tienen algunas certezas y
algunas sospechas evidentemente hay uno
que es el efecto de la niña que
es un efecto que tiene que ver con los
calentamiento enfriamiento de marinos
que hace que haya menos precipitaciones
en nuestro nuestra zona por menor
evaporación marina pero también se
supone y hay mucha información que que
establece que todos los que son los
manejos de tierra decir los nuevos todo
el proceso de deforestación genera
también todo un impacto en lo que es la
evaporación la el escurrimiento de los
ríos está intervención humana puede
estar jugando su parte especialmente
como amplificadora de los efectos de la
sequía y al limitar la capacidad de
autorregulación de los ecosistemas algo
sobre lo que ponen el acento los
movimientos ambientalistas
nosotros venimos señalando que esto es
mucho más que una emergencia o una
crisis hídrica es en realidad una crisis
ecológica una crisis de biodiversidad y
una crisis climática
una emergencia en la que se ven
afectados estos ecosistemas y todas las
personas que dependen
del río paraná